these innovations in tools and schools
make the opportunity for people to learn
worldwide better every single month I'm
Catherine manga award i'm here with
reason TV today we're speaking with tom
vander ark who's the CEO of getting
smart and one of the people you want to
talk to you about the future of online
education Tom thank you for being with
us good to be with you tell me about
this future of Education where are we
headed what's next well we've seen this
explosion in mobile technology so
learning is becoming mobile it's also
becoming modular but for most kids it's
still going to be it's still going to
happen at a school down the street and
so we're starting to see really
interesting combinations of online
learning and face-to-face learning
people call that blended learning so
learning is becoming blended it's
becoming personalized and increasingly
competency-based which means kids show
what they know and they progress based
on mastery one of your projects has been
too kind of incubate encourage and fund
us early education ventures can you talk
about I think for some people you know
that seems like it might almost be
attention there like you're trying to
make money on education explain why
that's the wrong way to think about it
so I left philanthropy about eight years
ago a little bit discouraged about the
four hundred nonprofits that I had
worked with none had really achieved the
their full ambitions and the sector had
almost no rd there's just very little
investment in innovation and compared to
other sectors like health care which is
also a public delivery system where
there's a dramatic amount of research
and development and a really important
contributions by the private sector that
hasn't been true in learning so what
what's happened in the last five years
is that billions of dollars have been
invested in startups that are building
new tools and it's really these new
tools that are powering new schools new
learning environments that have the
potential to work much better for
students and teachers get specific for
me what's something that you've had a
hand in
directly indirectly doesn't matter so a1
startup is Edmodo it's a social learning
platform it's used by about 45 million
teachers and students worldwide makes it
really easy for teachers to make and
manage assignments another one is
Coursera it's used by Tenma 10 million
people worldwide as free access to the
best professors in the world class dojo
behavior management system used by 35
million teachers and students all these
resources available for free to teachers
and that's why they've really gone viral
worldwide so now you're kind of on the
tech side you started your career as a
superintendent can you talk about I find
when I'm talking to people who have
developed a super great new tool or a
nap or something and they're like the
tech is perfect all we have to do now is
get it integrated into the schools this
should be no problem and it's always
like oh god you have no idea how hard
this is going to be you know someone
who's kind of been on the on both sides
what what is it the people are missing
why isn't there greater faster uptake of
some of these good tools well one you
know one exciting thing I can report is
that it is happening these free and
viral tools are being adopted by
teachers worldwide so there's kind of a
new back door to the classroom teachers
are and parents and kids are finding
these tools and and putting them to good
use so you know more than a third of
Americans classroom have these new tools
teachers are finding them kids are
bringing their phones to school really
cool things are happening from the
bottom up and then we're also seeing
superintendents and school networks
being really thoughtful about investing
in technology so improving student
access to technology and helping to
create new blended learning environments
so some thought leadership and a lot of
teacher leadership and and then parents
helping to hack their own kids education
so it's coming from the bottom from the
in from outside in and and in some
places from the top down so this is
happening faster than most people think
yeah I don't listen to your answer I
almost want to believe you I almost I
almost want to be out too
think about it but isn't the status quo
still basically that the vast majority
of kids are told you know they can't
even have their phone at school most a
change that changed last year it last
year was the first year where the
majority of school districts dropped
their ban on cell phones and at least
left it up to teachers on whether and
how to use the technology so it's
happening really fast and you know what
happened in 2010 tablets came in we've
seen in since 2010 the the the price of
devices has plummeted broadband has
become more ubiquitous most parents have
a smartphone so most parents even
low-income families are connected to the
Internet so the digital conversion is
happening fast you also have been
involved with the XPrize folks at talked
about just kind of in a general way why
do prices work and then more
specifically how can they help education
so so today I at the conference I spoke
about why prizes and pull mechanisms are
are so attractive the main reason is you
can't really mandate innovation and we
need innovation in learning that because
the opportunity set is so great so what
what states can do is use prizes and
other sort of demand aggregation
strategies incentives to encourage
innovation so they can give new school
grants they can great innovation zone
where where innovation can happen they
can put our rfps for new capabilities
that don't exist they can run prizes for
new new data systems and those kind of
strategies invite the world to work on
your problem and and that often works
much better than trying to mandate a
solution do you ever get sick to death
of the word innovation no every day you
just love saying that word I love it and
I I'm convinced that learning is the
most important thing for individuals for
families for communities for countries
and the really exciting thing is that
these innovations in tools and schools
make the opportunity for people to learn
worldwide better every single month and
right around the corner is the chance to
ever to educate every young person on
the planet we're really close to being
able to create low-cost blended
environments so that the 500 million
young people today that don't have
access to really good secondary will be
able to have it and that's that's five
not more than ten years away and that
that means where politics allow there'll
be no excuse for for not giving every
kid on the planet the chance to plug
into the idea economy I think that's a
big big deal last question this morning
we heard from Jeb Bush who may or may
not be running for president would you
vote for would you vote for Jeb Bush and
if you did what would you want to see
him do so Jeb was I think the best
education governor that we've had in the
in last 20 years I've had the chance to
work with Governor Bush and his team for
the last four years he has gotten even
better on education issues he has a an
informed and intuitive sense about the
opportunity set that I'm excited about
and for that reason it's been great to
work with him and his team thank you
very much i really appreciate you taking
a minute to talk with us today for a
reason TV i'm katherine bengi war
speaking with tom vander ark CEO gettin
spark'd
you